"And I know you, 'cause
you're from my hometown."
"Richard Ramirez."
"Night Stalker."
"You just died of cancer
in your cell a few years back."
"So that was a f*king lie."
Bertie's back, bitches, and she
wants to play some strip pictionary.
Yes, another season of "American
Horror Story" has come, it's so sad,
and Think Story is here to
break down the final episode,
and I gotta say, I really enjoyed this season.
I know the campiness - get
it? - isn't everyone's cup of tea,
but overall, I gotta rank
this in my Top 3 Seasons.
That being said, don't
form a mob or anything,
but the final episode for me left
a lot of unanswered questions.
And there were some character arcs that weren't
fully fleshed out and lots of plot inconsistencies,
so I may do one of my "How it should have ended"-
videos if I have time in the upcoming days.
If you haven't seen the one I did
for last season's "Apocalypse",
I've left a link in the description below.
We are back at Camp
Redwood, this time in 2019.
An Uber drives Bobby Richter,
yes, the now adult son of Mr. Jingles,
to the abandoned camp, which hasn't been
touched since that ill-fated Fyre Festiv-,
I mean, Camp Redwood
Festival back in 1989.
Bobby passes a rusted wood chipper,
foreshadowing the kickass gore that's to come,
We can see by the entrance sign:
This place has seen better days.
And even the stage hasn't been touched.
I'm still a little bitter we didn't
get to see Evan Peters as Billy Idol.
Bobby takes pictures with his cell phone when
Montana appears, who asks him what that device is.
No one has really visited the place since '89,
so she wouldn't know what a cellphone is.
When he tells her he's the son of
Jingles who's come looking for answers,
she gives him a hug.
As we'll find out, Montana has turned a new leaf.
Killing isn't her priority,
at least not anymore.
Just be careful what
you say around her, Bobby.
What did you say?
Taking Bobby to the cabin,
we also see that Trevor's there.
He has survived his tragic dick
shooting, which we'll get to in a bit.
Bobby has a scrapbook filled with information
about the camp, including all of its victims.
He tells Montana that his aunt on her
deathbed told him the truth about his father.
That's why he's now all of a sudden ventured to
the camp in search of answers 30 years later.
He's also the luckiest person on the planet,
receiving anonymous checks from someone,
and wants to find out who sent them.
Unfortunately for Bobby, the
ghost of Jingles hasn't been seen,
Montana saying that she saw with her own
eyes him being taken away by dark forces.
She's referring to him being thrown overboard
by the drowned, deformed corpse of his brother,
the one he was supposed to be looking after, but instead was perving some counselors making sexy time.
Montana grabs Bobby's gun from his backpack
to prove that she can come back to life,
that's like a great party trick,
when we're transported back to 1989.
Margaret is pissed, because the
talent is nowhere to be found.
She's chilling with Ricky and Bruce,
and when Courtney comes in telling
her that Trevor has blocked the road,
she shoots him in the face.
So disrespectful after he
cleaned up that entire tour bus.
And I think the only thing more offensive
than Trevor's shirt is this dude's troll hair.
At the entrance to Redwood, Trevor has slashed the
tires of what appears to be Kajagoogoo's tour bus.
He's done with putting up with Margaret's crap and proclaims to his wife his undying love for Montana.
But Margaret won't let him get away with this.
She shoots him not just in
the chest, but in the dick.
"That's got to hurt. I don't
care where you're from."
And if getting shot in the dick wasn't terrifying
enough, he was shot over the property line,
meaning if he dies, he won't
resurrect as one of the ghosts.
Montana appears, but she, too, is helpless.
She can't cross the line to save him,
but it's Brooke who comes to save the day.
She's turned a new leaf after
almost killing the journalist last episode,
and has embraced the good
side, helping Trevor over the line.
Back in present day,
Montana catches Bobby up to speed
on what happened to Margaret, Bruce,
and of course, the Night
Stalker himself, Ricky Ramirez.
The ghosts ended up banding
together to put a stop to them,
even using Midge, this character here who you might remember as one of the original 1970 massacre victims,
as a decoy to kill Bruce.
I also love how he holds the
knife here, 'cause he has no thumbs.
Trevor stabs Bruce and kicks him outside the
bounds of the property, so he won't be able to resurrect.
Ramirez, however, is a different story.
They just can't kill him and
chuck him off the property,
because he'll just resurrect by the
power of Satan and go off to kill Bobby.
Montana's plan is to
set up a death watch,
lure Ramirez into Lavinia's shack and repeatedly murder him every time he resurrects until the end of time.
I mean, I guess the
alternative was to let him go,
but since Montana says there are tons
of ghosts there, they can take turns.
Xavier uses a chainsaw,
and Ray even unleashes his inner Annie Wilkes
by hobbling his legs with a sledgehammer.
- "It's for the best."
- "Annie, please!"
And I will say Ramirez' death is probably
the goriest death we've seen in ages to date.
Like, I'll get demonetised
if I even try to show it.
As Montana says, the ghosts
took up Mr. Jingles' mantle,
protecting Bobby in the world
from the evil that is Ricky Ramirez.
We then are sent 20 minutes earlier, where Bertie
puts the moves on Chet, leaving Ricky unattended.
But the thing that's even more far-fetched
than this scenario is the fact that
tonight of all nights, Ricky
escapes not just once, but twice.
After 30 years, Ricky attacks Bobby by
throwing this huge ass knife into his back.
I mean look at it.
And I love how he just kind of forgets
he has a giant, life-threatening gash in
his back the next few scenes at the asylum.
Ricky really wants to kill Bobby as payment for
his dad's betrayal of both himself and Satan,
saying that he needs to pay his debt.
But Bobby is saved yet again by the ghosts and told
by Montana to go to the Red Meadows Asylum.
Now, this is also the last we see Ricky,
which was kind of a letdown for me.
I, I guess we're to assume that the ghosts
once again continued their death watch?
Uh-oh, guys, who's on death watch?
Bobby arrives at Red Meadows,
the same hospital where his father was kept
and had been subjected to electroshock therapy.
Bobby strolls in looking like a hobo
and just expects to speak to the director
at what is probably 11 o'clock at night.
Bobby, how do you think
this is gonna go down?
Then these orderlies come in and
take him away, which I think is illegal,
but whatever, I'm here for it.
When he mentions his father's name,
a name which Donna Chambers,
the now medical director, recognizes,
it's kind of ironic that she's the director,
since she was the one who orchestrated Jingles'
escape from that very institution way back in '84.
She tells him Margaret was the
real killer and recounts her story.
The angry mob of ghosts have surrounded
the cabin while Margaret loads her gun.
But it's Donna who's the first
to take a stab at her - literally.
Brooke comes to save the
day, but in the scuffle is shot.
We'll get back to her in a second.
Margaret is brought out to the wood chipper where
her limbs are systematically cut off one by one.
"I'm already dying."
"Right, we'll call it a draw."
It's only fitting that Trevor gets to call the shots here
as revenge for his elephant truck getting shot.
And he friggin' Kobe's
her head into the chipper.
Now, it's really easy to miss,
because it happens really fast,
but when her head, which Montana says can
live 30 seconds after being decapitated,
is thrown into the chipper,
the wind blows her guts back
onto the Redwood property,
which is why I guess
she was able to resurrect.
Donna tells Bobby that she was the
final girl, that Brooke died that night,
but if Donna wasn't the one
sending him checks, who was it?
They're able to locate the post office by
tracing the routing number found on the checks,
which leads them all the way to Oregon.
It's there they find Brooke is still alive.
Not only that but she has her
own family, her own normal life.
Now, Emma Roberts is supposed
to be like, 50, 60 years old here,
and I love how they try to brush off that she doesn't
look old by saying her husband is a dermatologist.
Okay.
Donna is upset and for good reason:
she's carried this guilt with her for 30 years
that she was responsible for Brooke's death.
And I gotta be honest, Brooke's response that
it was just too hard for her was kind of weak.
We find out that Ray was the
one who helped Brooke out.
The bullet went right through her
and says he'll get some bandages.
Ray, you're probably gonna need a lot
more than bandages for this one.
However, I forgive it because they do
this cute iodine and bandage throwback,
which is a nod to their first somewhat
romantic encounter back in episode 1.
Ray leads her to the edge of the property and all she remembers is passing out and waking up in a hospital.
And somehow the tour bus that was
blocking the way has magically been removed.
Brooke sent checks to Bobby as her
way of coping with what had happened.
She said she needed a glimmer
of hope in all the darkness.
She had seen that a once evil
man could find redemption,
turn his life around and start
a family and be a good person.
She also knows how Camp Redwood
has a way of pulling people back.
Perhaps if Bobby was given money,
he could break free from this "awful legacy".
Brooke and Donna turn out to be
the final girls and I gotta be honest,
I thought Brooke's ending was pretty weak,
considering they built her up to be probably
the closest to a main character this season.
But let me know what you guys
think in the comments below.
Outside Brooke's, Bobby tells Donna
that he has to go back to Redwood,
that he felt something when he was there.
I guess Brooke was right that the camp really
does have a way of pulling people back in.
It's at Redwood that Bobby meets Margaret,
who survived her trip to the wood chipper.
She says she's the only one
who knows where his father is.
How she knows this is never explained.
Maybe she's lying, I don' know.
And later when Jingles appears before Bobby, we
never get a clear answer how he magically shows up.
This to me is one of the more
frustrating aspects of the season:
the rules surrounding the whole curse and
resurrection stuff is conveniently twisted,
so that the writers can adjust it to fit
whatever plot point they're trying to achieve.
For example, in some episodes the
bodies take time before they're resurrected,
and in others they magically
appear moments later.
Jingles isn't able to be found for
30 years, but then comes out at the end.
Where was he when Bobby first arrived?
Where was Jingles this whole time?
Somewhere at the camp or in his own personal
heaven, as I theorized in my episode 8 video?
All of this is very muddy, but I still liked how Bobby
was able to finally meet his dad and grandma.
(Chorus) Aww!
Jingles asks Jingles, jr. why he came back,
and he says it was to thank him
for the sacrifice his father made,
so that he could grow up and be free
without the specter of Ricky after him.
Lavinia is the one to kill
Margaret, which is kind of ironic,
since Lavinia was the first massacre perpetrator
killing Margaret, who's the second and third.
The ghosts say farewell to Bobby and Montana talks about how the 80s will never die, just like themselves.
With the final scene taking place between Bobby and
his family, his grandmother, father, and uncle Bobby.
I'll get more into this if I end up doing a
"How it should have ended"-video,
but the thing that disappointed me the
most was the lack of closure for the ghosts,
specifically a few of them who had cool
backstories and traumas that were explored,
yet their redemptive arcs
were never really panned out.
I would also have loved to have seen more
lore behind the curse surrounding the camp
and tie-ins to other seasons.
I think they missed a valuable opportunity to tie Ricky in with Michael Langdon and last season's "Apocalypse".
They have so many similarities,
yet that was all glossed over.
Overall, though, this
season was fun as hell.
I don't think there was a
dud episode in the bunch.
As much as I throw shade at
the show, I do it out of love.
So I hope you'll consider stabbing
that like button, subscribing,
and leaving a comment about
what you thought about the season.
You can also follow me
on Twitter @ThinkStoryYT.
Until next season remember,
Daddy loves you very much.